ted is standing by with your forecast
what he has done is compiled a bevy of
photos of the lightning storm last night
look forward to seeing these ted and
lots of videos too because a lot of the
viewers send it to us and we appreciate
that so we're going to share something
with you right now on our news now
social kate got this great shot look at
this guys great shot of the lightning
storm to the east says now we captured
some lightning on our camera from our
backyard facing east across northwest
part of the valley this one from trevor
great shot here from trevor a massive
lightning and rainstorm looking down at
lake mead yeah that's where all those
storms were at focusing right over lake
mead lake las vegas boulder city valley
of fire and this one from band showing
us that cloud to cloud lightning and
this viewer sent us this one as the
storm was starting to pop up way in the
north northeast part of the county 100
evening current temperature right now
for sky canyon and same for you and
centennial hills 97 for aliante thank
you so much we'd love it when you guys
sent us your storm picks and your storm
videos we love showing those off to
everybody 99 whitney ranch mountains
edge you're currently 96 91 for anthem
right now
94 for prompt 97 boulder city 102 for
lachlan we're going to always switch up
our neighborhoods for you your current
temperature so no neighborhoods are left
out a little more on that excessive heat
warning now that goes into effect on
sunday at 10 a.m goes all the way to
monday 8 p.m las vegas not in that
mesquite not in that and searchlight
laflin not in that but those areas
westward southern nye western clark and
over to inyo county yeah we're going to
get some hot temperatures maybe up to
123 out of death valley
over the weekend into monday storms are
diminishing across the region right now
look at all that just dodge las vegas
again we're getting some of those clouds
over us right now zooming out still a
little activity towards the east of us
high pressure again in the southern
great basin this is going to head off
towards the east in the four corners
region that will open up the door again
that southeast flow giving us better
chances for thunderstorms we think
next week in the meantime futurecast
doesn't give us good chances for tonight
we could get some light showers in the
morning tomorrow from the storms out
here in mohave county but that's about
it here's your forecast 85 overnight
partly cloudy it will be humid 106
tomorrow partly sunny and hot or mainly
mountain thunderstorms for tomorrow your
highs neighborhood by neighborhood right
around 105 in spring valley along with
north las vegas 103 centennial hills 104
mountains or i should say a henderson
101 for prim and 104 for boulder city
here's your extended forecast your eight
day forecast here on eight news now
we're gonna stay hot for the next few
days increase your chances for the
monsoon to return again by tuesday knock
down the temperatures a little bit the
humidity goes up and sunny hot again for
later on next week
that is your most accurate forecast back
to you